[Musik]
bild gk
und nach dem locker und für sachsen
denen wir heute morgen exklusiv
vermeldet haben der womöglich kommen
soll die nächste hammer nachricht unsere
kollegin kyra ortmann hatte vor wenigen
minuten die möglichkeiten mit hubertus
heil dem minister für arbeit und
soziales zu sprechen erfordert kein lohn
ohne test oder impfung
bei mir ist jetzt noch
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil von
der spd die spd hat ja diese neuen
gesetzesentwurf ja auch mit 4 auf den
weg gebracht und es steht da ja drin
dass nun auch 3g am arbeitsplatz gelten
soll schließen sie betriebsschließungen
komplett aus erstmal geht es darum dass
wir alles tun diese welle zu brechen und
wm in italien erlebt das 3g am
arbeitsplatz also es heißt genesen
geimpft oder trieb zumindest getestet zu
sein als voraussetzung ein betrieb zu
betreten sehr geholfen hat die
infektionswelle da zu brechen aber das
wichtigste ist eine hohe bereitschaft
von bürgerinnen und bürgern und das ist
das was wir in deutschland brauchen um
die welt auszubrechen ist aber bei einer
weniger hohen beziehungsweise bei der
aktuellen impfbereitschaft
betriebsschließung nicht ganz
ausgeschlossen wenn das
infektionsgeschehen weiter so bleibt wie
bisher lokal ist es nicht ausgeschlossen
dass es jetzt nach der rechtslage heute
schon so und auch zukünftig aber wir
wollen wo immer das geht das ganze
vermeiden und wenn sich alle an die
regeln halten und wir die regeln auch
konsequent durchsetzen kann uns das in
deutschland auch bewegungen menschen
müssen sich impfen lassen wer den
arbeitsplatz betritt muss ab kommender
woche
nachweisen dass er geimpft ist oder sie
und wenn das nicht da ist wenigstens
einen tagesaktuellen test nach bringen
wenn wir das nicht tut dann davon den
betrieb nicht betreten und dann muss man
auch damit rechnen dass zum beispiel
lohnfortzahlungen frage steht aber gäbe
haben das zu kontrollieren ich bin froh
dass gewerkschaften und
arbeitgeberverbände diese regelung
mittragen weil sie wissen dass wir nur
so die chance haben schulen und kitas wo
immer es geht offen zu halten auch
betriebe offen zu halten ist ja unser
ziel sein und ist auch eine frage der
solidarität am ende der des tages der
bürgerinnen bürger sich impfen zu lassen
mit denjenigen die jetzt jeden tag auf
der intensivstation schuften als ärzte
pflegerinnen und pfleger es geht auch um
den schutz von älteren und vor kranken
und der kinder das ist jetzt eine
nationale kraftanstrengung aber ich
setze darauf vernunft aller beteiligten
die große ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
was erhoffen sie sich daraus was sind so
die wichtigsten punkte die da in ihren
augen geschlossen werden müssen einigen
darauf dass heute keine taktischen
spielchen oder parteipolitischen manöver
gefahren werden alle haben verantwortung
zu tragen ob zukünftige opposition oder
regierungsfraktionen im bundestag
alle ministerpräsident
ministerpräsidenten wissen dass die lage
ernst ist gerade mit blick auf das
geschehen in bayern sachsen thüringen
müssen wir das für dramatische
entwicklung haben und deshalb setze ich
darauf dass alle ihrer verantwortung
gerecht werden und auch das richtige tun
kann das gefühl dass die union solche
spielchen betreibt wenn man zum beispiel
auch an den brief den herr wüst an unter
anderem auch olaf scholz geschrieben hat
wenn er da eben nicht für diese neue
gesetzeslage stück es geht ja am ende
des tages um die richtigen maßnahmen und
wir sollten nicht um begriffe streiten
so unserer verantwortung gerecht werden
das gesetz sieht sehr sehr harte
maßnahmen vor viel mehr möglichkeiten
als es nach der geltenden rechtslage
gibt sondern ist auch aufeinander zu
bekommen in den letzten tagen und mit
ein bisschen vernunft aber vor allem
verantwortungsgefühl wird das in
deutschland auch gelingen das richtige
zu tun wir sollten aufhören mit
schuldzuweisungen zu arbeiten dessen
land das kann man gerne machen aber wenn
man verantwortung hat und das hat man in
regierung und opposition aber in jedem
fall ministerpräsidenten
ministerpräsident ist dann gilt es jetzt
darum das richtige zu tun und sich
gemeinsam auch unterzogen